okay thank you
every to the 10 people that are still
watching
thank you thank you this is a serious
message
okay we will not let technical
difficulties define us
thank you crew for scrambling to get
back to our serene
beautiful uh lakeside
good luck ethan thank you keemstar nice
guy always thinking about me
so today in lieu of our half-life
disaster
we are going to be reacting to
just watching hanging out if you guys
have suggestions
send um we've got some fun videos to
watch though
let me open the stream so i can see chat
um oh amarathan's looking let's check in
on her
this is how i like to start all my
streams
16k good for you girl get it licking the
mic
[Music]
maybe we should call our stream looking
the mic
yo did twitch figure out how to um
it's a bypass ad block because we always
get ads on them it's pretty impressive
yes they did good for them yeah they uh
don't work bezos is on that [ __ ] you
know um
god i'd be rich if youtube figured that
out
so um she's still looking how long she's
been she's been going for four hours so
we'll check in on her when we're done
do not come i'm trying thank you kamala
i'm going to come trump's going to come
stay hydrated my friends
stay well when you're looking that much
you got to stay hydrated
you're just losing fluids with every
lick
you know so shout out
all right here we go chug in the water
here we go all right from from the top
actually wait i forgot to open the
[ __ ] twitch my twitch channel
okay guys um okay guys
now i have to mute myself it was a
disaster guys sorry
it's the worst stream ever sorry
all right here we go let's react to some
stuff guys
all right so up first here what is
so we have unusual memes first is this
the one that i was watching before that
i was having a goo
a goo and a gaff at yes it was
do you have a specific one or should i
maybe i'll sort by most popular
oh my god this one probably just the
recent one because otherwise we'll have
clips that people seen
that's a reaction video
[Music]
okay i'ma set it up
today we will be watching unusual videos
now i am not one that easily laughs
and i've been assured
that these can make can move me
or surprise me at the very least real
quick
yes i'm seeing a lot of people suggest
you watching and reacting to the new
channel 5 video
oh that's such a good idea that's a
pretty good idea let's watch this and
then we'll do that okay once i've got it
open that's a great idea
love that idea
okay so here is unusual memes
compilation version 103 man this guy
works hard
53 million views holy smokes let's go
what's up on friday
from the screen maybe full screen it's a
little quiet for me too
thank you thank you peace and love peace
and love
that wasn't unusual just a guy messing
up on the skateboard
i vetoed that video
full cream of chicken we're gonna get it
to pour perfectly into the bowl ready
[Music]
interesting that is unusual
i feel i'm not a good reactor i'm just
sitting silently yeah
i like it give me jinx reloaded
vibes yeah i mean i'm not even
commenting i'm just sitting here i'm not
even smiling
you know reacts harder okay i'm gonna
try okay yeah maybe some louder here we
go i'm gonna
lift it up come on ethan you're a
reactor now
act like it
there we go can i still throw stuff at
you
um no sure i don't know about the
gatling gun that things
no not that i just mean like yeah you
can shoot me we should share why not
cool
yes whoa
that was freaking awesome dude dude that
was
insane insanely unusual
the thing is about this is that
can you really add anything i mean the
videos are funny
can you really add anything substantive
to this compilation
i mean we have conversations as we go
along
really like this one like this meta
conversation yeah like that last
that last clip reminded me of how
shredder pushed me the other day and i
didn't know dogs pushed like that and i
was amazed but i guess it's normal
yeah shredder does well i don't know if
it's normal but shredder does it
he does it to everyone he does to me too
he jumps at your leg yeah two legs
yeah he's really good at it yeah pretty
amazing
there you go we just transformed this
content made it our own there we go
the cat couldn't get the mouse
it was like mission impossible
[Applause]
wow round of applause that was
super unusual wow oh this one's got a
crying laughing emoji so i'm ready i'm
queued up
i know just what to think
oh jesus wait let me go back i've done
that before i think i chipped my tooth
before doing that oh my god
oh jesus
pretty funny
we're done it's pretty funny you guys
[Applause]
ooh who asked you [ __ ]
you know this is actually quite
dangerous i hate to get dark on you but
like the peloton treadmill got recalled
because
this is this this is crazy but you see
how this ball gets sucked under the
treadmill
that was happening to children and
actually some kids died i don't know how
many
and peloton had to recall their
treadmill so
not fun and games guys not fun a game
that one is not funny
serious issue well zach we don't want
kids to die i'm seeing
one child one child died one is too many
a baby
yeah it is a child to die baby yeah is
that not enough for you ab
do you want more to die not a big deal i
was just resilient because i didn't want
to say one kid died so
jesus babies disappointed not more kids
died from the treadmill
okay true color shown
i don't find anything funny about this
poor puppy that's that hungry
okay can we feed this puppy more this is
not good
not funny please show that puppy more
love give it to me i want that puppy
no
no what are you doing
oh god
oh we have um okay so we have some intel
on how to make this more interesting
uh we're gonna learn how xqc reacts
he's the king i guess uh he reacts to
unusual memes so let me take a
okay yeah let's take a a book here so
take note of this thumbnail too look at
that wow so much fun he's having
is that dog driving that dog is drunk
last night can he do that dogs can not
get licensed
yo in california at least that's some
crazy content
okay so here we go full screen
full screen thank you love
good commentary so far uh you guys
i don't want to do it guys this is like
this is like the secret part of the
stream okay
when i stream at night okay what should
not probably not happen anymore guys
he's he's talking about his streaming
schedule
oh wow not even
[ __ ]
[Music]
holy [ __ ] are you serious right now
you just don't have what he has you
don't have that gonna sound like your
climax
is that what i'm supposed to do to make
this interesting
i'll try it hold on holy [ __ ] man
is he joking dude these
memes are really unusual and he's seeing
them for the first time hey babe
how did peach cobbler tasting this is
great you know i shouldn't watch i
should just watch him reacting
i think that should be our meta is just
reacting to reaction videos
right how many layers deep coming that's
people couldn't react to that
yeah because i find his reaction more
interesting i'll take my cue from him
oh people say it's been done well then
let's see well let's react to those
videos
reacting to react we can go deeper we
can always go deep
we can always go deeper
let's just not move on until we can all
agree that you did a better reaction
to every single video thank you so much
i'll take that
well i thought i wasn't sure where the
bar was but now i'm learning that
it's quite hot i'm pretty good at
reacting oh no oh i would say
we could add another challenge for you
to not pause one time
that would be interesting he can't do
that that's wrong no way trying to get
me sued come on wow pausing is the key
to not being sued my friend
no i don't know pause the yandy i mean
try not to pause challenge is a funny
idea
but i feel like i'll fail
okay so so he's not doing anything okay
this is good
all right well i got the let me watch
this one look how many omega walls are
going on
in his chat his jets having so much more
fun than our chat
you guys are slacking look at look at
all those omega lols on the xqc's
chat is that what this big donut thing
is
yeah it's it's the yeah yes people are
loving it
his his okay is so large that it's just
become like
oh look now they're spamming it there we
go thank you can we get some more megal
chats and
mogal laws and chaplains i'm getting
insecure
all right let's continue ethan the
master reactor now that i've learned
from the best
what the heck is that sound you guys
what the heck was that sound
give it up to that gap that's hilarious
has your dog
[Applause]
see if you can lift that dude you live
that that okay
i think there's too much weight on there
buddy
oh
that don't that even really makes sense
to me i guess that's what makes it
unusual
shredder does that all the time like
every night
but this guy is dedicated i like that
cute i love that dog sherry does the
same thing he claws and claws
and achieves nothing and then he goes
okay i'm ready to lay down it's like
dogs are thank you scooby am i right
great stuff
oh too slow there froggy
way too slow froggy uh oh he wants beat
he wants the wormy
what happened to xqc's reaction oh i
turned it off oh
i wanted to go back to our video i was
just a little training session let's see
yeah i'm dedicated i'm gonna
you know i am dedicated to this video
[Music]
that's pretty impressive honestly
that looks hard eh
anyone think they can do that easily
easily buddy
wow it's not looking too good bud
i don't think you realize what's going
on buddy
what are you stupid
now that's funny guys let's be honest
[ __ ] move man i can't see [ __ ]
come on
hmm he got way too mad at the video game
it's just a game man
it's just the game bro play that game no
but i've seen a lot of people playing it
looks fun i thought you did oh maybe his
ian
ian did you you played that game for a
while right yeah for a bit
you ever get that mad not that bad
you ever punch a hole in the wall no i
win too often at that game
all right that man sure you're not that
guy you're not that guy not that guy
where is
oh my god there's a bird flying on the
road
pull up
now that wasn't react now that was a
reaction
i'm trying dude
whoa no whoa
that's a walmart video if i've ever it's
the first one that's genuinely made me
laugh
i mean i have a lot of questions about
what's going on here in the background
how this happened it's at walmart
clearly right
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
walmart dude i'll have what he's having
you good bro he's got sandals with no
socks we love that
fantastic
this is a good thumbnail maybe eh and
then me going like this
that made me laugh
[Music]
three
i got the diaper fours dead stock
what the [ __ ]
oh we got a kitty in the water anything
can happen folks
i'm surprised oh we can't play that
what are you doing over here unusual
memes you know people react to this
oh he's got a fresh cut kirby giving
kirby a lineup
damn he's looking damn that kirby is
fresh cut bro watch out this kirby's
coming to steal your girl right now
no pace bro
you know that was a meme i remember
punching the shower ghost that's a
pretty funny one
i do like the the punching the shower
goes for me
[Music]
your best friend yeah
look at that cat looks like a loaf of
bread never seen a cat shaped like that
i like him i'm not saying i don't like
the cat i'm just saying he's i know
you're not
i'm just lucky gordo boy i'm just
looking them okay
that's a good reaction though dan thank
you you say i like him
i like him that's transformative nice
dan i like this does anyone not like
this cat i mean that could help
transform this maybe you
yeah hater i do like the cat i just
think he looks like a loaf of bread
he's a minecraft cat i don't like it
oh trump doesn't like the cat of course
he doesn't witnesses say that it was
definitely a scary sight
and i was just going to taco bell and
then i hear some gunshots and i'm like
all right
i guess taco bell can wait
good good observation dude hmm
shake my hand shake
put it there god damn it
[Music]
i forgot your act no way that
[Applause]
oh too fat uh oh no he can't make it
somebody help him
not like this he's too young to die why
did the kid always die young
[Music]
that's some cute [ __ ] i'm not even gonna
[ __ ] lie right now boy that's some
cute
[ __ ] my dudes
[Music]
fantastic how'd i do guys how did i do
love rate that
um i mean not a lot of time really is it
better if i don't wait you say nine out
of ten
yeah i mean would have been a 10 if you
didn't pause okay so let me try one
where i don't pause let me watch the
newest one
i don't know people didn't seem to like
when i said that for some reason
they probably like your your
like your touch i guess okay well hold
on no no no no no i'm gonna try
the the twit the real reaction way i'm
not gonna pause okay here we go this one
we're gonna add this one in here and
great you guys tell me which one's
better
[Music]
you're gonna say he missed him
[Music]
there is a person
yeah i'll see you around wet oh you
wanna gonna have a nice drink while
you're mowing
so you just put it right in the right
new little moen cup holder
[Music]
that doesn't that doesn't matter that's
not gonna work very well man oh hey dude
that thing go away man
shaky way too shaky channel five what
we'll do that after this are you
done that's not gonna work ah that's
what i thought was exactly what i
thought was gonna happen
oh oh dogs love me something's about to
happen
everyone's saying this is bad content
and boring
i'm just i'm reporting to you how old
are they
why are you doing that spice it up spice
it up you know
okay let's do channel five actually ew
this looks like not right
like this [ __ ] is like gooey and not
right at all
that's that's what it's supposed to be
like well look at my sleeve oh i'm sorry
it's like someone puked on me like baby
puke or something it's a nice shirt too
it's [ __ ] up baby why'd you do that
all right someone link me um
channel five i do wanna watch that
actually there we go that's more like
getting
the discord wait xqc was just banned
what the [ __ ] did he do
did you see that in shots yeah i just
saw it in discord xqc
he got banned what did he do fourth band
he was watching the olympics on stream
oh man
that's live dmc that's the emc
yeah they really don't want people
watching the olympics apparently here's
what's [ __ ] up about that though is
like
you're making an assessment that he's
not doing a fair use
commentary before he has a chance to
make that argument
by you by then
interfering with his ability to give
fair use commentary
and and taking it down like that and
then why does he get banned why does
twitch make that distinction like
you you're you can't make that
assessment of if his content was legal
or not if it was
dmca it wasn't twitch it was probably
the olympics well it sounds like twitch
abandoned though
yeah yeah right already
he's always on band okay that's good
just a quickie
i'm banned after five hours or something
but it's like you know i just the dmc
[ __ ] is [ __ ] up it's not a re-upload
the man is watching it you cannot make
that assessment
that it's not fair use like that that
that should be illegal it really should
be
i mean i don't know you you got it on
the laptop too
so before like a while ago speedily all
streamers on twitch
were forced to delete all the vods
because uh
twitch said that you have to do it or
you might uh get the dmc
all your votes literally like all your
work well you know these big companies
are scary right so
yeah but i think the big problem was the
music they were playing as i understand
it because the music itself
is hard to tr i mean it's you can't
really transform
like copyrighted music if they're just
listening to music you know
i would be more worried about that and
that's legit right you can't just play
people's music
um some you got me the channel five guys
yeah it's in there with the buff dude
all right
okay so andrew
from channel five news all pre formerly
known as all gas no brakes
i've kind of now doing it going his own
way which we're all happy about i'm so
happy andrew's going his own way i give
it an instant like you see that i don't
[ __ ] around wow
that's how it is for my homies instant
light i don't even need to watch it to
know it's a masterpiece
you know and so he a q a
conference i mean this this is
perfection this this couldn't get better
um i'm really happy he's gone his own
way though because i'm sure he's making
more money he has more freedom it's
fantastic that guy's such a talent
i a huge fan so let's watch this
let's all get terrified by cuban on
people been searching for the truth my
whole life
and one time i just came across a video
that
was about biden and kamala harris
and yeah where'd you find that video
take a guess everybody vote where she
found that video
my would say facebook it's yes it was
definitely facebook
there's no question in my mind it was
facebook on the meat chef
you know facebook is radicalizing people
it's straight up
they like i don't think that like
january 6 would happen without if
facebook didn't exist like mark
zuckerberg is like
the biggest terrorist in the world right
now he's basically running his
facebook isis he's osama bin laden
mark zuckerberg is osama bin laden i
don't i don't know
he's the metaphor tracks completely i
agree that it's damaging though
he is the leader of a of a
of a dangerous cult he's osama bin laden
you heard it here holy spirit straight
up
clinton and obama they are satan
worshippers
satanists worshipers
and i couldn't wait to tell my family
and they just go
they just said you're crazy trump's the
worst
how does that make you feel sad i cry
all the time
but i just keep praying that's all i do
i just keep praying and asking god to
open
their eyes i have a beautiful family
they're just blind
which family member do you miss the best
my baby sister i told her we're in a
spiritual warfare this is between good
and evil and she rolled her eyes
what's her name meg we go and have wine
together and lunch together and
it's gone
[Music]
actually quite sad i mean q anon is it's
actually it does tear families apart
because like
when one person thinks that we're having
an existential a civil war a war for the
spirit of america or whatever she said
um you know and you really believe that
how can you reconcile your relationships
with people who
are thinking that q anon's
lunacy you know it's breaking families
apart it really is
i mean and and and there's a lot of
people that believe qanon it's
it's it's uh shredder's puking here real
fast
okay you all right tree thank you
he's okay shut her pukes a lot it's kind
of his thing
don't worry about it everyone gets
worried when i say that he his his breed
of yorkie
is uh they puke a lot they get like a
buildup of stomach acid and then
[Music]
you know what happens they puke
so dogs are low maintenance so basically
she's been radicalized by osama bin
laden aka
mark zuckerberg i mean the man
prioritizes money over
tearing apart he's tearing apart america
he really is
i think facebook hell yes tries to ban
all the q and on stuff but obviously
they just like
crop up with that don't try that more
once you learn you don't turn back i
know what god wants of us and what jesus
wants and it's what trump
wants and it's what the patriots want
i would never turn back no matter how
many of my family i lose
[Music]
i have been censored three times
disabled permanently disabled on
facebook
censored permanent okay
they don't like my q mobile and they're
sure they all don't like me in my q
patriot costume
i like her q mobile you know and it's
always the same people i hate to say it
it's
like yeehaws you know i'm saying it's
white trash
it's all has to do with god it's a lot
of that but it's definitely not all of
that
this conference is in uh texas right
is that where he's is that where this
conference is taking place
so obviously you're going to get that
but um no there's a huge q and on
contingent here in los angeles they
protest almost every weekend
oh that's good so they have a family for
them they get together
yeah a lot of because of like the
spiritual aspect a lot of the people
that are into this are
honestly more california
hippy dippy naturalist
you know anti-vaxx anti-gmo
type people that's interesting because
the um
the capital viking the cuban on viking
or whatever
it was super famous that guy it was like
a vegan yeah
no yeah the the the bratzo world people
are very much into all of this as well
it comes from all types the amazing
thing about q anon is that
somebody says just say white people it's
it is a it is mostly white people
to be fair uh it's not all it's
near my house pretty often oh for real
yeah yeah
i even saw andrew at one of them one
time
i love how active with all the um
like netflix building and all that stuff
yeah in hollywood
because they think that hollywood is
part of the cabal and so there's these
anti-hollywood protests uh going on
here in los angeles do they have any
thoughts on the quite often church by
the way
uh you know i because probably
because you know it is a largely
evangelical christian which
evangelicals traditionally are not very
trusting
of the catholic church because but i i
don't think that's for sure
yeah but the the crazy thing about q and
on is like
i want this big documentary came out
what was on
hbo i think and just in general q
disappeared
all of his predictions never came true
this documentary pretty much proved it
was this kid
who who and his dad who owned a chan
yeah the watkins
like i mean um and so the fact that
people are
still so on board is pretty amazing to
me um by the way here is a flat
just uh basically uh fbi's most wanted
currently
so so keep if you see this man please
call the fbi
thank you thank you cameron i'm the meat
chef
yeah he's the meat chef all right anyway
let's continue
we're only like a minute and a half
through this thing man
but andrew i just his his his method is
so good because
he manages to make these people feel so
comfortable and open around him
these people hate the media but they'll
talk to andrew and so
we always get really fascinating and
really genuine insight into them which
is why andrew's such a genius he dressed
perfectly i was
just gonna say i think the harley
davidson shirt helps a lot
he's the best man he's going all the way
to the moon man
where we go one we go on i don't even
say the m word anymore right
what the m word it's a it's a dirty word
it's uh
[Music]
now i have my own words instead of the
words that i know the algorithms are
going to shut me down
can you tell us what words you use for
which we're not going to shut you down
uh mask
the face diaper vaccine the jokey pokey
and election yeah the jokey book is
pretty funny
i'll tip my beanie to that i got i've
got my jokey pokey twice so
this i think sam said called it uh the
the fouchy ouchie oh the fouchy ouchi is
good
that's pretty good guys get your fauces
please fraud see people don't understand
everything that we've learned from day
one
has been a lie we never on the moon
i don't think the hitler situation is as
bad as they said it was why did we go
why we gotta tie in holocaust denial
like it always comes down to
anti-semitism
every [ __ ] conspiracy theory always
comes down to anti-semitism
well if we would just stop controlling
the world maybe people would stop
that that's a joke yeah i'm drunk
in case people didn't get those being
sarcastic well i always joke you know
there's this big jewish conspiracy i
don't ever get the [ __ ] memo i don't
get my dividends from that
jews yeah i don't get around to those
meetings very often
love it charles that was the
rockefellers those are naughty words
in social media i got banned forever on
facebook yeah that's probably channel
five
after a half you know it's funny it's
like and and somehow not only
did the jews lie about the numbers it
was the jews fault for the holocaust to
begin it's like no was the rock it's
like dude
bro come on give us a break here all
jews
yeah i know keemstar i think a few weeks
on the road covering events like the
pickup artist boot camp in las vegas
america is back open baby it's make out
time
[Applause]
that was a great video by the way
can we just make this a can we just make
this a channel 5 reaction
channel yeah i'm down this is so
i mean it's great it's actually great
because we get content and we get to
promote him
he should pass pewdiepie go ahead
someone in shots said that there is a
tos
thing about a girl in the capital got
killed
i'm apparently is showed i'm watching
ahead right now to check
oh there's something i can't show in
this video i'm going through they just
don't want
thank you guys and creating my first
solo documentary about two twins in
marin city california we've been
everywhere and on a [ __ ]
[Music]
i decided to dive back into the world of
right-wing politics
that's when i discovered the god and
country patriot roundup a three-day
event in dallas which cost
three thousand dollars not including a
stay at the omni hotel in dallas
which costs an additional one thousand
it's pricey to be uh queuing on
what i found there was a couple hundred
patriots they're gonna have to stop
coming
uh around the ten minute mark okay thank
you i've been banned from
facebook instagram twitter tick tock
this is uh
joe biden's daughter's diary i used to
make videos like reading it out loud
i've lost two
youtube channels three twitters and four
facebooks
every time it's like oh yes it's funny
they think that them being like
shut down is a sign of them they're on
the right right but it's actually it's
not it's just a sign of you guys being
psychotic lunatic
uh danger dangerous psychos
you know can we give a shout out to the
chat for catching that
yeah thank you chad please stand up
thank you stand up chat
stand up everyone everyone watching
stand the [ __ ] up right now
stand up thank you guys thank you very
much kevin i see you stand up
come on kevin you better be [ __ ]
standing in your bedrooms or wherever
you are you're at work if you're in the
car
standing on stand up you're in summer
school
stand the [ __ ] up okay all right dan
geez
stand up you know dan you stand yeah you
didn't stand up
thank you dan no no no that was the part
of the [ __ ]
oh dude how much to get that fart spray
right in your nose bro
me yeah i'll definitely puke
i could take some money though i got my
brother-in-law's wedding coming up you
know my answer
how much you want the rolex i do it for
a roll for a [ __ ]
fart spray would you out of your mind
500 bucks
to do what in your mouth just no not in
the mouth just right in your nostrils
500 bucks oh i just the nostrils i'll
drink the [ __ ]
is that mouth yeah well if i'm buying
you a rolex it better be in your you
better be drinking a lot let's go
i'll drink the whole bottle for a rolex
yeah well don't worry thousand bucks in
my mouth
five hundred thousand in my mouth
50 bucks i mean i would totally take you
up on that level do anything for a buck
well you guys said i do it for like 200
bucks in the mouth
what do you swallow 200 bucks ian yeah
would you swallow it you seriously
swallow it wait a minute wait a minute
is this even safe to do let me read this
okay
wait 200 why are you guys lowballing
dude
listen it's just not that it's not that
uh it does say non-toxic
but then it also says do not ingest
you've accidentally ingested drink two
glasses of water
oh well that's not that yeah you don't
have to drink it just spray it right in
your face like
three times right in your face two
hundred bucks wait three how many times
are we negotiating i feel like one spray
is all you need to do two sprays okay
two sprays one one spray destroyed this
room okay no that was two i almost few
okay wait let me set up the parameters
of this okay
here i'll spray it i'm gonna spray it
directly in your face
for 200 only 200 bucks for 200
people saying dan you're supposed to be
responsible i am i read the label
what more do you want we're not putting
in his mouth we're not 200 bucks i'll do
it
we're not putting it in his mouth i'll
do it for 200.
okay ian are you watching maybe we
should save this for after dark though
um self-harm term of service it's not
self-harm we're not putting it in the
mouth it's far too
bad this platform i'll drink it for two
grand
for two grand just swallow it for two
grand i don't feel bad about fart
fart spray it's not we're not drinking
it the who whoever brought that up no
we're not ingesting it we're just
spraying fart spray
zach brought up drinking it i i said
just i said just like a little
no no no yeah exactly guys no it's not a
mouthful so just
in the face for 200 bucks can mean do it
together i'm not paying both you what
the [ __ ] am i
i got the offer in first yeah that's
true i'm the first one to say
hold on hold on ian you went up to 250
what the [ __ ] is this
i'll take 200 okay 199 i'm going to do
it to eat
we're going to practice and i want to
see you in so okay so here's here's the
deal once you're going to directly
to the face and you can't you have to
sit wait for oh wait ian has the post
coveted thing
are you yeah are you starting right now
you see
you see are you sure i know you have no
do you have no sense i knew something
was up my price just went back up
earlier you could okay i'm just he's
fine it's been a long time
no he was just talking about it he has
the long covert he said in an episode
yeah i know he has long coven but it's
been a while listen i
this will blast through long covert i'm
not afraid i want to see this [ __ ] yeah
okay so again 200 bucks and you have to
sit through it you can't like get up
wait what if he has to puke well if you
can't puke on camera that will get us no
don't peek on camera but i'm saying you
have to sit there for so that we can
enjoy
sit there for a minute well it's going
to be in your face so if you get up and
move it's not going to help much
it's not even going to smell it i mean
i'll do it for 200 okay but you can't
get
what the people you have to stew in it
okay but we're gonna suffer through it
you guys can move just ian can't i'm
going to put on my mask
all right so here we go you agree ian
fine [ __ ] it okay here we go
this is set for me by the way wait i
don't know why are you gonna be over
here
love is saying we're gonna get banned
but it's bark spray i mean no trust me
i'm just telling you it's fart spray
give me yeah i just i'm just going on
the record
warning you this might be too or this is
probably tears
okay well banned me then he's gone on
the record i don't want to be on a
platform that i can't do a fart spray
like i'm sorry
fan me then ban me right now we'll go to
youtube
it's fart spray it's literal [ __ ]
just
harmless fart spray all right
i mean theoretically we already did it
like a b
pretty much sprayed it at ethan earlier
open up your mind and that was on stream
i have uh i have one more condition uh
a b needs to take his mask off no yeah
yeah i'm gonna go put mine on right now
you don't get to control what
he does i'm the one sitting back here
and i'm not even wearing a [ __ ] mouth
the one i'm paying whatever
a b does is not has nothing to do with
this
here will you fix the camera maybe
you messed up you got a better reaction
on me all right so you all can see
now this is i don't know if you guys saw
the first part but this is the worst
thing i've ever smelled in my life
how close did you do to my face baby
yeah i'm a homie okay so here's the fart
spray
it's called butt crack smell yes you're
gonna have to talk into a knife
okay yeah so so so here's here i'm just
gonna tell you
because the first spray may not be a
full spray so i might have to do two
here do one first to kind of get it it's
bad
here and then we need a foot give me at
least like give me this no
yes okay like this
okay okay i'm going to cover my eyes you
can cover your eyes you can cover your
eyes
but just for the record for twitch this
is not dangerous
it it's non-toxic it's non-toxic
non-flame don't do this at home just for
safety it just smells bad and don't do
this at home i guess i don't know it's
it's fart spray it's not it's nothing it
just smells bad yeah and i'm proud of
you
i'm very ready yeah i'm proud of you too
this is out of character
it goes away all right all right ready
guys all right
okay so so it might be like it might
well if
it's a partial spray i'm gonna have to
do a second one
because sometimes the first one doesn't
go all the way that's true no he's right
all right if you try and sneak a spray
my ass goes up
no it's it's one full spray okay okay
ready
here come come a little closer i'm not i
know i'm backing up i just want the
camera to see it i'm back
they can see it they can see it okay
ready
all right here we go oh that was a good
spray so i'm not gonna do two sprays
that was a full spray okay
here you could go up to the microphone
ah
oh god that is i got a little oh then
figure
i'm still switching what a champion
he's still switching
oh my finger ian you like kind of
open your mouth for a second look like
ian show yourself oh
dude it's like a cat [ __ ] in my mouth
it's the worst thing i've ever seen oh
[ __ ]
oh i just i got like one little
sprinkle on my finger it's
so bad i don't smell it start crying
dude i wonder what's in this thing
oh god it doesn't have ingredients
but it says it's non-toxic and it's as
if you ingest it to just drink water
which
makes me feel like it's nothing that bad
this says in bold
for novelty use only i'm sorry what
other uh
not for serious use only for jokes
oh how you doing ian give us a status
update
it's nasty but my hands stink too
because i did this
it's just
[Laughter]
zach's gone the thing is that the first
time you smell it it really catch you
off guard
when sam gets back she just tell her
that you accidentally [ __ ] your pants
it smells like that yeah it's not like
that and so you had to use your hands
well good job ian
proud of you dude 200 200 hard to earn
dollars
wow uh dan can you come switch while i
go wash my face i don't really want to
go over there
i'm not part of the deal yeah i can't
sit in this dude it's so nasty
i mean this is what you signed up for
what i have to go over there now
and sit in your chair that you just no
but seriously i
there's like a cloud of it in my face i
gotta take care you can take a moment
zach got expelled zach zach come on you
got to do the audio
you got a job to do dude
like [ __ ] that's been dead for like 10
years ugh my fingers stink
so bad oh a b stepping in
okay thank you okay maybe he's got the
got the uh the reigns now
i'm surprised ian agreed to do that like
that's very out of character for him
yeah
that's why i was like is this a is this
like a covet thing
weeks back here ian ian uh had coveted
uh [ __ ] i mean almost a year ago now
right it was like the fall of last year
yeah he was an early he got it earlier
he got it relatively early and it um
and he says to this day his taste really
hasn't recovered is that a b or zack
no he's dying man oh no abe tried to sit
[ __ ] dying
switch to you a b
a b is and he's doesn't know what we're
doing
maybe he doesn't know him
[Laughter]
not one of the keys you're pushing all
right there it is okay you got it
dude he's dying man that that is
that is nasty that was a good 200 bucks
so i'll be honest oh my god
i just can't stop smelling my finger
ultimate game of stink finger
[Applause]
man when i was a kid they were like
little glass files
is he throwing up in the no that i just
heard gagging in the bathroom
oh no i think he should be okay you
can't let me go oh
no yeah oh yeah he's
puking oh he's not doing well
we're getting a status update from from
ian
stalwart thank for the 20 subs gifted
hey
thanks man stalwart twenty [ __ ] thank
you brother i'm gonna need that how does
that work
exactly when i i don't really get it
like when they i think it just gives out
randomly to people watching so just
non-subscribers can just randomly be
assigned one of them oh that's cool
yeah it is cool huh yeah we appreciate
the gift
yeah very much thank you so much so i'm
just i'm a little
i'm worried about poor ian now i think
he's all right
i mean he's all right like he's not he's
not gonna die
we hope it does smell but that might it
does smell that bad
it's just [ __ ] dying it smells like
he's puking
no he just switched to himself and he's
his his eyes are rolling in the back and
he's wearing a [ __ ] mask
i'm not even wearing a [ __ ] mask what
a gangster you are
yeah you're tough guy tough guy you big
tough guy oh
god well let's i guess should we wait
for ian to resume the video
uh a b start pressing random buttons
until it pulls up uh
channel five again i'm good it kind of
weared off
what am i doing switching to uh let's
wait for the video let's wait for ian
he's coming shout out some more gifted
if you want yeah go ahead please though
yeah
three gifted subs thank you
we salute you sir mr santa bay i think
that's a member of our discord actually
gifted 10 subs
[Applause]
wow we give you salutes
yarrow flower shared 1000 bits one
what does that mean i think a bit is
like a penny
[Applause]
it's 10 bucks apparently 100 thank you i
love the [ __ ]
thank you for the 10 just now let's
another 10.
wow
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you
so ian's still out of commish huh
zaki you want to go check on him give us
a shout update yeah
what's the update how's he doing cam
he needs a few minutes he says he needs
a few minutes the dude underestimated
this [ __ ] like i'm i wasn't kidding man
this
is not a joke i'm so shocked that he was
down
i think he thought he'd be fine but he
thought he had it handled what a [ __ ]
legend man
the the instruction says avoid highly
vented ventilated areas
for maximum effect oh right because the
whole intent is to prank somebody by the
way this says the instruction says put
it right under your friend's nose
okay what are the ingredients is there
ingredients listed
no i was trying to figure that out not
list the ingredients which is
worrisome well it's their special recipe
i think it's just homeless people's uh
[ __ ] they scoop off the street
and bottle it that makes sense i think
my chat arena is making annoying little
notifications michael xd five gifted
subs we have a bunch of gifts that are
flying in right now angry shows
angry shoes one gifted thank you thank
you tall bear
five gifted oh dunk stream raided us
with five thousand viewers wait who's
that dunk
duncancino dunk stream
[Music]
maybe not oh well thank you dunk stream
we love
dunk stream oh oh it is it is stung
dunky
it is donkey oh i love dunking man
jason's on the jason and lee are just
the best
i love them thank you duncancino
duncancino
what's that name duncancino it's the
biggest fame
don caccino ian's back ian welcome back
ian donkey we love donkey
ian please stand up there it is ian tell
us tell us how you're doing please
walk us through everything that you're
experiencing dude
i can't get it out it's like in my beard
it's like
in my face did you puke just now no no
no
i tried to rinse it out like oh okay
no but are you regretting it no it was
all right okay
feels like i did like a letter litter
box keg stand or something
well i was just saying to the guys the
instruction
says put it under your fri right under
their nose so
we were just following the instructions
yeah
it's like baked into my nose i can't get
the smell out i think it's in your beard
i like to be a dick which kind of like a
horse it'll dissipate
it'll dissipate yeah all right let's
continue forth
shall we let's go
oh right we're watching a video by the
way 10 minute mark
yeah around 10 40 was that got it
exactly
10 40. people are saying you need to
shave the beard now ian is the only way
to get rid of the stink damn rip
all right where were we duncancino
um the so-called pizzagate uh conspiracy
theory
well first of all i had like 300 000
subscribers on youtube the last couple
of videos i did were all about the
hunter biden laptop issue
within 48 hours of putting those out
they just deleted my channel right away
and then within two weeks of that i was
deleted off of twitter as well
yes we were recently uh kicked off
twitter
because of a confrontation i did with
the vp of integrity at facebook
if we weren't making a difference if it
wasn't that important why would they
spend so much effort and energy into it
i mean all of silicon valley is
validates their work is that people are
shutting them down
it just means you're a douche it just
means you're an [ __ ] like damn
so we're in war it's no different than i
love the shot
they were doing to the buffet lines to
the jews and different things they
silence them they're just doing it
through social media and
electronically now it's a war of the
minds it's psychological
i love how they go on one hand the
holocaust was
greatly exaggerated but on the other
hand we're just like the jews
they can't make up their mind about how
they feel about the jews
right it's emotional it's mental it's
actually worse than having bullets and
missiles
the only real difference between woke
supremacists and and the nazi
supremacists the white supremacists the
old south
is is the technology available to them
they don't need
to put the jews the other into ghettos
because they can now electronically
ghettoize us
they in fact this jew is electronically
ghettoized they have removed my voice
from the community
i am endlessly being imprisoned in
zuckerberg school logs
and again it serves exactly the same
purpose as stalin's
day walk people wake up it's pretty
ridiculous yeah except you can literally
leave your house
you can go on any social media you want
just don't like
spread conspiracy theories that are
harmful and dangerous
so i guess if you compare it to jews who
were put in a ghetto couldn't
leave or taken all their possession in
homes and then eventually shipped off to
their eventual uh murder and genocide
i guess i totally see the uh parallels
there to being banned off of twitter
yeah to being banned off twitter right
yeah no it's
pretty much the same thing it's a
digital holocaust it's a digital crystal
knockout yeah it's a digital crystal
knock totally
uh yeah there's no difference at all
you could say that triller is doing a
digital uh holocaust on on me
um they are yeah that's true
ryan cavanaugh is gassing your ass he's
digital hitler
yeah he really is it's so awkward you
know
in a metaphorical sense he is a little
legendary little hitler
literally literally metaphorically
ryan kavanagh tried to put that in a
complaint right and he called me literal
digital hitler
right what did you mean by literal
digital hitler uh ethan
during the deposition well you see we
were watching channel 5 and
imagine trying to explain that even can
you check the discord real quick
i don't know how important this is but
it better be [ __ ] important
oh i hope this doesn't mean no
thank you but we moved that thank you
not important thank you though for
reminding me god bless
outraged by a misgendered toy plastic
potato
it's pretty ridiculous to be outraged by
the shape of a syrup jar
shaped in in in the design of a beloved
black ant are you talking about mr
potato head in jamaica
it is ludicrous to be outraged by a
drawing in a 70
year old children's book of a
hard-working
asian man that was somewhat cartoonish
because you know what you know why it
was cartoonish
because it was a cartoon goddamn because
it was a cartoon
well it sucks and but is it really your
place to care about those things i mean
what does that have to
it's like i just don't the lack of
self-awareness of saying like
you know people shouldn't be upset about
this thing but he's upset about it
clearly very upset about it he's like
he's upset that people are upset about
mr potato head but it's like it's
upsetting to him yeah
i mean the whole mr potato head was just
a fox news talking point because the
truth is they didn't disable mr potato
head
they just marketed it as potato head
so that because there's a female potato
head you can still get mr potato head
can i can i i think it's just called
potato head now
you know they didn't like that i want my
potato to have a [ __ ]
big [ __ ] dude that's a big [ __ ] plugin
yeah my mr potato is [ __ ] jacked bro
he has a massive penis you know
big dictators said somebody yeah on them
big dick daters
i like my mr potato head with a big old
[ __ ]
come on now i don't want no [ __ ] boy
potato head
i want a potato with a big old juicy
[ __ ] oh dictators
oh dictators i'm i love my dictators
i love donald trump and i love mr potato
head with this big old juicy [ __ ] now
deep fried baby
it's shaped like abraham lincoln
[Music]
yeah come on down here now our potato
heads have genders
down in texas we still have mr potato
head it's utopia
he has a massive penis that's why we
fight and now what we've done is
between president trump and people like
you and
podcasts like myself i love that he's oh
my god
he goes i love he had to plug himself
real fast
it's called flex the truth podcast what
is going on
flex your muscles holy [ __ ]
i love how he goes people like donald
trump q
and me reflects the truth baby we had a
voice we
are the news now when people want to
know the truth where did they go
alternative platforms like rumble bit
shoot d live twitch
foxhole pill cloud hub uh puresocial.tv
um i used literally what what are those
platforms i've never heard of them flex
nut potato nut mr potato [ __ ]
i'm still not over the aeropostale
hoodie without sleeves i can't imagine
him buying that in the store and
everyone not
laughing their ass off he may have
converted it himself you know
tell grandma i love telegram i have
great group chats on there
i do a lot of stuff in the community in
the streets i go stand at squares and
hold signs for the kids
operate wow it sounds like you're really
in a ghetto
he's like i go on the streets and hold
signs and talk to people and move freely
but i'm in a ghetto like the jews in
1009 save our children
and human trafficking we have to return
to the oldest technology of all which is
one-on-one conversation that's not
technology that's literally just
your mouth that's not technology i guess
everyone at this event is pretty much
deep platform there so i guess this is
kind of like the way for them to uh
that's brace by the way he's wearing a
[ __ ] bite and so that yeah they're
fitting right in
it's pretty great out figure out what's
next
how you doing big fan hell yeah doug
what's on your mind
i just met a group they're called like
down for the re-vote or something and
they're like doing a justice for prince
thing
they think but like a few days before
prince was gonna die he was gonna out
hillary clinton on like eating and
raping children let's go find them
that sounds like a good lead right there
that guy looks like andrew's stunt
double
that's true he's out there filming too
i love that you gotta chase down those
[Music]
leads
was murdered and we absolutely have
already proven it by mathematical
standards
prince had been exposing things about
what math math
yeah what which standard are we talking
about
well let's see the equation
mathematical let's check the proofs on
that yeah
deep state illuminat illuminati cabal i
called the worldwide communist network
and um and i think we all know that when
you do things like that and you use your
celebrityism and your platform um to
speak these truths that are
not allowed right by the one-eyed crew
then um you get hit
i tried so hard and got so far
but in the end it doesn't even matter
it's true we're working out dude rip
chester
two words were never said my dudes
these people are unstoppable man these
people are leading the revolution
there aren't too many legends around
there there aren't
is who is a legend zack we love you
you're very special
dan is a legend isn't that somebody you
have
uh no it's not he is a legend no he is a
legend okay yeah
chester bennington is the lead singer of
lincoln park he and chris cornell were
um going to expose hillary clinton's
pedophilia jeffrey epstein was essential
in facilitating
so she said lincoln park
was aunt was was preparing to expose
hillary clinton's pedophilia like like
well
lincoln park hold on let's not let's not
give all of lincoln park credit because
only chester died and they
they chris died too chris killed himself
no i'm not talking about i'm talking
about within lincoln park yeah
yeah you know i actually heard um
who's a you know i heard that bill cosby
was working to uh
where uh who who's a random celebrity
that recently died
not bill cosby yeah yeah i heard uh mj
that wasn't recent
yeah i actually heard that um dusty hill
from zz top rusty
man easy top was working to uncover rip
to a sharp-dressed man
my dude was working hard to unveil uh
hillary clinton's pedophilia so
they got him too can i can i just make a
quick chris cronin i'm
i mean i'm one of his biggest fans he's
the reason i got into music i've never
heard anything about him being involved
in any
[ __ ] like this let alone chester oh okay
well well
thanks i'm glad zach would have heard
yeah yeah uh
zach wouldn't know yeah you should talk
to these q and on people because
you pretty much just dismissed the whole
thing right there i appreciate you
setting the records fit on that side
yeah
michael jackson also never told me
anything either so
i think he's clear michael jackson
love it you got you got to park dude i
keep putting you in the charger and then
you roll forward
well i mean the lovebot has a mind of
his own love but
lovebot is very damaged and ever just so
everybody knows there is a new love bot
uh that actually just arrived a few
hours ago about 2.0
2.0 for friday because it has just
fallen
on the ground very hard far too many
times
and uh this one is on the front the new
one has three wheels
and this the first the one was like a
uni wheel but like
i don't know it just it doesn't seem
that stable it's not stable enough i've
spent four thousand dollars on that
[ __ ] thing
and it's like on its last leg literally
it has one leg but you know what i mean
to be fair we've
okay we have a bit gentle with it but
still
quite a lot i may have run it over on
the gatsby
a few times he is responsible for the
murder of multiple people
including nipsy hustle what yes um
nipsy hustle is one of my spirit guides
and i've
just worked with his energy and guidance
um
since his death where do you get your
news from from
divine source from from god we are a
prophetic justice ministry
i do not watch tv i don't watch truth
you get your news from god where can i
get that feed
subscribe god have a newsletter or
something i could follow
yeah you just have to tithe that sounds
legit though i love that
they've got all these great these
amazing claims and what's your
new source god oh geez
i don't watch the internet this is your
source do not really even read books
i've channeled all of my life i've
always heard his voice and my accuracy
is constantly at 99 to 100 percent
we're not 900. so there's a margin of
error there
she has gotten it wrong that's good
before i don't know how you're it can't
be a gap between 99 and 100 because 100
would imply that you never got anything
wrong it's got to be at 99.
it's got to be 99 or a margin through
99.99
or something right exactly i wouldn't
feel comfortable saying a hundred
which she's really the fact that she got
that wrong is putting into doubt
the mathematical proof that she claims
that she has because she clearly does
not understand how percentage 99.9
repeating yeah from there part of the
cube movement we
align with some of the things that cue
has said
we really came out to just network with
this community so
love and honor and infinite love and
gratitude to prince and nipsey hustle
upon further research i learned that
this was not just any patriot conference
the event is hosted by john ceballo aka
what time stamp was that
8 30. okay just want to keep these pages
a conspiracy theory that a deep state
insider is spreading messages on the
image board 8-chan to expose people like
hillary clinton and bill gates
saying they belong to an elite cabal of
satan worshipping
i don't know what brace you want to come
in here q1 is the theory that an
individual or a group of individuals
are exposing the deep state uh including
hillary clinton and her baby eating ways
through the imageboard 8-chan which also
has a lot of child porn
yeah that's a great uh irony of the
whole thing
yeah i love that this guy is awesome
either donald trump is q
or he's behind it he is like a
christ-like figure who's come
to the office of the presidency in order
to
arrest and execute every single person
who they don't like
but right now is a weird time to be a q
supporter for years q has talked about
the storm a day of reckoning in which
trump along with the military would
arrest all the members of the deep state
and save the world
but the storm never came it's weird to
be a qn person now because for five
years qnr people have believed that
nancy pelosi etc would be arrested and
executed in guantanamo bay prison in
cuba
and uh to this day not a single person
has been and on december 8
2020 q stopped posting i think the last
post
was a scene from last of the mohicans
and then a gif
of an american flag flying over a full
so legit
that's basically it
oh yeah this is it stop stop stop just
skip forward to like 11 minutes
okay yes oh a whole 11 whole minutes
well no to the 11 minute mark i'm sorry
okay so we're skipping all this yeah
thank you thank you with people today
we'll come thank you thank you with
connections
maybe i don't think that the storm
didn't know i think we're good yeah okay
thank you
guys thank you this certainly happened i
think that
the whole point of it was for a vast
majority of people to wake up there was
still things wake up
wake up zach
wake up thank you you know i mean we've
got the audits in arizona wisconsin
i trust 100 that there's a plan i think
it's dan scavino
mike pompeo i think you know we're
obviously not allowed to hear about
certain things because it's a military
operation
and you know i have complete faith it
doesn't ruin my hopes that
you know a lot of people aren't talking
about it they don't want to get kicked
off facebook
part of the reason i believe we're in
this problem is that's why everyone's
not talking about q anon that's the only
reason
no you're living got a lot of high
school friends
that you know you're in touch with
that's the only place that you can get a
hold of them so
it's not worth saving the world from
pedophilia no
yeah yeah you gotta you gotta weigh
those options well that you don't wanna
be thrown in a ghetto i mean it's like
that bad a digital ghetto you're facing
a digital you're facing genocide
potentially if you speak
digital genocide right digital genocide
it's because we've gotten conditioned
for instant gratification q is the
template it doesn't matter what q does
it doesn't matter what trump does until
we're willing to participate in
something different and be a part of
that
see we are the plan we are the storm i
think they did their job
you know they started the great
awakening i love they go
so now the queue is gone and no
prediction came place now it turned into
q is a state of mind the storm is just a
state of mind
i don't understand how any of them
cannot look at january 6 and not
like that was the storm that was your
chance you're never ever going to get a
chance
at the storm as good as that and they
failed like they just need to kind of
accept it like
okay you know some version of the storm
came to be
and it just it didn't really accomplish
anything i think it's time to get
give up on the storm dreams the storm is
is in the mind it's a mental storm i see
uh yeah it's a mental storm i think
that's called those brainstorms i think
that's called a seizure in other words
yeah if you're having brainstorms check
with a neurologist
disappointed when q stopped posting back
in december no
no no because they did their job am i
disappointed in trump no
trump did his job now we have to as
people take back our country and not
wait for a hero one of the tactics of
this new psychological war
seemed to be avoiding cue the main
speakers of the event
general flynn and sydney powell claimed
i cannot believe these [ __ ] traitor
pieces of [ __ ] that woman was on stage
literally working with trump's lawyers
for
months after the election and this woman
is doing a q anon
country tour i mean these people are
traders man
these people are just a bottom of the
barrel scum buckets dude
digital uh you might call them digital
uh serial killers
well we're at it let's not know anything
about what we're talking about
ready right here okay thank you andrew
okay i thought he was in a full adidas
tracksuit for a second
just the top it's still good well
because that's
that's like i mean i don't want to
stereotype but it's like which team are
you playing for
with the full adidas jumpsuit because
that's like
you're trying to are you making a
disparaging comment about eastern
europeans right now yes i am
how dare you not disparaging i didn't
say it doesn't look good sukup dance
that's what people say
it's been a while since i've heard of
sukho yet man
i used to play dota 2 a lot and it was
all
channel 5 action news so uh channel 5
from where though
channel 5 action news is
it's the name of our youtube channel i
got it i think i knew that about it
it's not syndicated through a national
broadcasting corporation but you know
dude shout out to andrew got a [ __ ]
uh question off on general flynn i mean
this is next level so talking about
manipulation if you go on any mainstream
media platform they describe
this whole event as a q anon conspiracy
conference yeah
why do you think that they're doing that
and is that true
if they create this this booking ad
right they create this boogeyman that's
a nice little thing to just
keep beating us about they try to take
an organization like this and create
that level of noise that i talked about
cueing on including they're the domestic
they're the new you know they're the new
shiny object
i don't know what qa9 is i really don't
i'm just at a q a rally
where they're selling q on merch and
flying queuing on flags
i mean how can anybody claim that they
don't
like everybody's at least heard of it at
this point no it's just like you'll see
he did i mean obviously he's
full of [ __ ] but
daddy flynn eddie flynn's part of the
storm that's why we go to these events
and collect
and that's why we go these the events
and get paid like 5 000
or something for an appearance fee
that's part of the storm baby
i'm part of the storm for a fee right
what's my speakers what's my speaker fee
i'll be part of the storm yeah
sounds real legit i really don't but i'm
going to leave here
saying well do you believe in god
general flynn was going
to be real sneaky as he delivered his
speech vendors in the back sold queuing
on hats and t-shirts
and he's caught one of those he's even
wearing a big fat q on the back of her
motorbike jacket
yeah he claimed to not know what humanon
was but months before
he took the oath with his entire
extended family
was this guy really a general he sure
was
now that's [ __ ] scary that
is very concerning that there's people
like this high up in our military
i think he's far from the only one
that's just my opinion
well maybe q's real then i mean if you
know what i'm saying maybe he's out
there
maybe he
listen on the fourth of july last year
where we go on we go all
he he was the military man who knew
about the hillary
clinton scandals and what they've been
doing for years like
his truth is what brought the movement
alive
and you know whether or not he's in it
he's the people's general he woke us up
whatever it was he had a role in the
great awakening shout out to general
flynn uh where are we going we go all
right
we just talked to general
well media look what they do when they
take little pieces of it and they
they we've been ostracized we've been
talked about we've
through our families we've lost loved
ones wives have walked away parents
everybody is
ostracized in a certain way it's not
because they're wrong
it's because everyone else in the world
is right it's like the tin pool the
quote
right it's not me not me anybody else
everybody else
yeah in their own communities and it's
why give them the opportunity not
surprisingly other speakers follow
general flynn's lead what are your
thoughts on the whole like
q anon thing i don't know about it i
really don't and you know i only talk
about things i know
like are you familiar with arena
football arena football
like the sport yeah the sport so like my
roommate was one of the old owners of
one of the quote unquote rumors
um you know event in general has been
called okay he was chained up in my
basement
quote unquote roommate roommate he was
in my digital basement
being digitally genocided
the qnan conspiracy theory rally
even says where we go when we go all on
the lanyard
what are your thoughts on that whole
thing i don't know
i'm just here to talk booker t
washington is the father of black
conservatism
his three-point plan of education
entrepreneurship is self-reliance
we need to bring that back do you really
think booker t washington was a
conservative
pretty sure his whole thing was radical
he was like let's free the slaves that
seems like a pretty
i i don't know if you're thinking of the
right person
booker t washington i was like the first
black
author or something black american
author i feel like you're thinking of
frederick douglass oh i am
[ __ ] me who's booker t he's the father
of
black american conservatism is who he is
all right [ __ ]
i take it all back they're both yeah
they were both authors educators so yeah
douglas shout out to fred liz douglas
shout out to fred frederick douglass
frederick douglass the man you know i
call
shred you know what i call shredder
shred shredder stuck shred shredder dug
let's move on
i see the crystal raindrops fall
and the beauty of it all when the sun
comes shining through i think trump is
the best thing that ever happened to
black people in particular
i represent the hood from st louis we
kill each other every day in the black
community
when a young girl is sitting up on her
bed doing her homework
and a bullet comes through the window
there's no black lives matter
but as soon
as a white police officer grabs a black
person the wrong way
put the finger in the face the wrong way
black lives matter
can't both be wrong yeah both can be bad
for sure
can we care about both from what i
understand this uh well i mean
i guess i should hear the rest of what
he yeah yeah but yeah
yeah i mean a lot of uh i think trump
increased his percentage of the
african-american vote by
uh like the most significant margin in
years yeah
for republicans so this guy's opinion is
actually far from
i heard unique i find that really
interesting yeah
nothing to do with the matters of black
lives
what are the undercurrents that are
hiding behind the black lives matter
movement
first of all it's it was started and it
was started by
two lesbian uh black lesbians who hate
the black family
this is the best self report ever that's
why andrew's such a genius he goes
okay he seems on the rails he's got
opinions he goes why so who's why is
people hiding behind black lives
he's like oh it's it's too lesbian
oh i get it oh there you go that's why
and there it is
yeah exactly the war against blm and
antifa rages on okay auntie
i'm speaking to you so what i saw
yesterday
is uncalled for when you're sitting
there making up lies flex for freedom
bro
that are involved with you and on when
you're sitting there spewing
ugliness make sure you know and educate
yourself
and don't be spewing out venom he's
spitting went through our interview
fake news arrived
[Music]
oh i don't even know what i'm doing oh
is that fake news
fake news will how you doing brother oh
trying to get in huh that's the dude
from uh you know that guy
no that that's the dude from the
documentary that you watched
one of the dudes uh they're from the q
anon anonymous podcast which was like
the uh podcast that was tracking all
this cute stuff
interesting i remember seeing this on
twitter that he got kicked out of this
conference
interesting so here it is all caught on
tape there you go good
try to get in huh not good well
yeah get out of here schmuck yeah i mean
i guess
i mean they're not fans of mine i think
q anon john who runs it is not like a
huge
fan of my reporting well i guess he's
not one of the hosts but he was a
frequent uh guest on it i see
the daily beast you know people just
like aren't huge reporters in general
what qnon tells you is that like the
most powerful people in the world
just committing the most heinous crimes
they're abusing children with impunity
right and only you and donald trump can
stop it and so if you believe that
then like yeah of course you're going to
be on board with q and on and i think
like
it cracks me up and look they call
themselves digital soul is he
just leaning there for effect or is he
filming or doing something
or is he just there for style hold on
it's pretty fun and look
is he just there he's just there for
style he's he's the dark cowboy this is
one of his personas that he does
he's just there for style dude i thought
i figured he was like recording or had a
boom or something i think he just
yeah he's just he's just vibing love
that
they call themselves digital soldiers
right it's like you're like in a war
do you feel bad for these people yeah
for the most part i mean i don't feel
super bad for like the people who are
promoting it
and like who i think are often cynically
making money and ruining people
um but yeah i i typically feel very bad
for the average q a believer because
you know it's something that it preys on
your emotions right it's like almost
everyone i know
they have a story about someone they
know who has like lost their mind to q
and on
love the buffet it's just it's you know
it's war
digital warfare and mashed potato and
gravy
and fried chicken
gotta eat yeah you know garb up the
worst coming boys
get those carbs [ __ ] fried chicken
[Laughter]
the caterers we're actually doing food
these are the gators
[Music]
no way i did what do you think he was
trying to say that's classified ew
his mom
[Music]
it's not that good i mean it's like
shaped nicely but it's not like
she's not that hot it's like that it's
like curves in
i am a menace eat his booty out
these caterers are not taking cue
seriously
cigarette okay let's distinguish it
[Music]
um it's a i love trump but i hated when
he banned flavored vape juice
not the savior now is he buddy
i want to know why what happened
in minamar can't happen
here that's so insane
what
[Music]
[Applause]
no reason i mean it should happen no
reason what
he's talking about a military coup yes
very cool the ex-general
very cool and and what's the purpose of
this
coup may i ask what is the government
that weren't to reinstate
the dually elected president united
states donald j trump
right right right right right thank you
dan
and thank you for clarifying well um
that was fun obviously the first part
half of the stream was a total disaster
but
i think we ended strong are you wrapping
it up well we could maybe watch one more
but i figured we got the reactions we
got the all gas no breaks
by the way andrew such a great video
like
it's easy to take for granted how great
it is but the fact that like that one
that uh daily beast reporter got chased
off and then he got him to sit down for
an interview i mean the perspectives he
gets
and the dedication and just the amount
um such a great video by andrew of
channel 500 paste in the link in the
comments right now don't like it thank
you love
yeah i mean that's like that video and
subscribe to his channel because he
still
has way less subs than he did when he
was all gas numbers
i mean that's great that's great he just
started it like a month ago or something
so
it's going really good yeah
he's at 760. yep so um
yeah i think it's a good time to wrap it
up
so tomorrow we got after dark on on uh
you yeah tube
so get there gonna go plan that i mean
we have to we have to work on that for
tomorrow true
so uh h3tv now officially is on mondays
and thursdays okay guys yes and remember
to sub
to the h3tv youtube channel where these
vods
and clips are going to live if you want
to watch
we're going to make the vods private
here because let's be honest i want
people to watch it on youtube
not twitch thank you terms of service
banned it is it i don't know probably
not [ __ ] you
just everybody says that about pretty
much anything i can't do a fart spray
love you gotta take it i mean we haven't
gotten banned yet we're still streaming
baby
yeah i feel like if we were in violation
they would have take us off i'm just
i'm just definitely sad to get through
no i appreciate it i appreciate it
yeah yeah devil's advocating guys right
yeah
ian how you feeling i it stinks oh
it stinks all right well let's clean ian
up let's get that man in the bath or
something let's give him a sponge bath
yeah all right guys thanks for watching
thanks for enjoying that first part you
know next week we're gonna have a new
sip so
it's gonna be great yeah yeah the raid
someone who should we raid
uh who should we raid let's see who's
live the channel
amarath is still licking by the way we
should just right here and send
everybody to the licking
hold on she's still like code miko's uh
streaming why don't we
he's ray komiko we haven't done her yet
has been going for five and a half hours
okay of pure ear looking madness
um i'm pretty sure if we amaranth and
zero people will uh remain
damn twitch really got me with these ads
huh
you rob is live oh you rob we did a rob
last week
did you guys see do you guys see the
clip from when we oh
i don't think ethan is aware of what
happened let's show me the clip i want
to react to that
that's so after the stream i didn't know
who to
to raid so i just threw it to europe uh
i didn't know what it was doing
but you'll see what it was doing but
turn what down
yeah so europe never wins
always else can you get me that clip
thank you guys for joining us today oh
it's the most viewed clip on this
channel thank you thank you i'm lincoln
uh wait it's the most viewed lick link
on his channel
yeah the most viewed clip yeah 115
awesome views of us raiding him
yeah well you'll see why the clip of it
okay yeah all my subs are just look at
all my whole
channel page is just asmr girls
because i always click amaranth i think
uh yeah that would definitely have
something to do with it
but i will never click any of these
other girls i'm loyal to her oh why did
i just open what's up
[ __ ] wait go off the screen okay
something comes up
thank you okay discord
thank you all right here we go i got it
wait this this is his number one feud
clip uh for a couple weeks yeah
okay here we go don't scare me like that
man
to you to buy that for twenty dollars to
get
stop please turn it stop on host
unrave me
so why was he in a furry suit not sure
we're not really sure but i think he was
upset that people were
coming in right as he was but he's
kidding right
like it's funny no he really wanted me
to unrate him because he was in a furry
suit
people are people saying he lost a bet
don't be
so he lost a bet so he was having to
wear a furry costume and then we raided
him
without realizing that that was what was
happening on his channel and he got very
upset
my page is pretty wild damn
so people are also saying gus johnson is
uh streaming right now so we could raid
gusts
i think code mikko though look she's
right there where's code mikko
right there okay let's see who she
chatting with
oh it's the technician no mikko sweet
anita too she also has tourette's
not a single man that's right oh
yeah they could be fun okay let's go
let's raid called mikko
all right her up
gusy would be good though well
we could also find a small person to
rage that'd be nice right i'll kill you
uh if that's true that's true just look
for somebody
sub sub 1000 andy yeah let's find a sub
1000 andy
dude everything is just booby boobas
raid my friend cam what are you trying
to are you getting paid off
cam's getting kickbacks
are they a small streamer cam
cam are they a small streamer
let's do it what's their name cameron
has a friend on twitch
um who is i think paying him a dividend
of
i just like loved it with the merch
she's [ __ ] sick as hell
all right let's let's uh yellow spoon
girl what is she doing what's her
thing new mic like making me [ __ ]
look she cutting up magnum condoms oh i
met her she's very nice
yeah this girl is delirious oh she is oh
fantastic
should i get my eyebrows threaded and
unkept bushy i mean the thing is she
cutting up magnum condoms oh
oh she's rolling up can you do that well
can we yeah yes you can do that
sure all right let's raid her it
everybody head on over to yellow spoon
girl
what's an automated thing wrap it up and
then we do it
yes sir all right everybody no what what
i mean we can do it
live too oh okay we can send everyone to
her live how
well it's like it's that's what a raid
is there's a feature in twitch that you
basically
send all of your viewership to another
channel
so i'm starting the raid now so everyone
in shots press right now freaking scared
okay
she's getting scared i'm just [ __ ]
scared
i don't know what in the heck is going
on
her name is bella she's very sweet we
went to a museum with her
oh you oh you met her through camp i
don't know what's gonna
oh she's i'm ready
there are a lot of humans in here this
[ __ ] is going up a lot good job
are people watching both of us now how
many humans in here
i don't know how it works but let's wrap
up the show okay guys go enjoy uh yellow
spoon girl
i'm getting really she's having a
nervous breakdown
was this a good idea cameron she seems
to be having a panic attack
oh my god thank you for the raid okay
have fun everyone shout out to
yellowstone girl this was way cooler i
like doing the shout out to little uh
yeah it's a good idea yeah spread the
love right
let's be honest oh god she is a lot okay
great you guys are going in okay so
um yeah everybody let's be honest um
code miko's already famous she rules
though okay guys
enjoy love you see you next time see you
tomorrow after dark all right
[Music]
you